بالتلميح والتصريح ازمه التعديلات
القضائيه تخرج الى العلى الخلافات بين
الحليفين القويين من واشنطن الى تل ابيب
والعكس ايضا يرفض الرئيس الامريكي دعوه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الى البيت الابيض
في المستقبل القريب فبايدن قلق للغايه يرى
ان الاستمرار في هذا الطريق ليس ممكنا في
اسرائيل
لا يتاخر يرد وبطريقه غير مسبوقه رد حمل
اشارات واضحه الى الولايات المتحده
اسرائيل لا تخضع لضغوط من الخارج بما في
ذلك من افضل الاصدقاء
وللاصدقاء تحديدا يقول وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي اعتمار بن غفير ان اسرائيل
ليست نجمه على العلم الامريكي متوقعا ان
يفهم بايدن هذه النقطه فهل فهمها بايدن
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه نقلت عن
مسؤول امريكي قوله ان نتنياهو اخطا فهم
الرد الامريكي على انقلابه القانوني
المسؤول الامريكي قال ايضا ان نتنياهو
اساء التقدير بتصريحاته حول بايدل خرجت
التصريحات اذا اصداؤها سمعت في اسرائيل
واشنطن لكنه صدن يعكس غضبا واحباطا
امريكيين من نتنياهو وحكومته كما تقول
صحيفه يدعو تحراوت نقلا عن مسؤول اسرائيلي
كبير